y con nuestro invitado el día vamos a
hablar de muchas cosas importantes
acerca de nuestra salud mental para ello
y nos acompaña nuestra cronista de salud
más Romero salamar bienvenida Gracias
por supuesto por acompañarnos en estos
temas de salud siempre es un gusto Raúl
vamos a hablar hoy de la Salud Mental
porque hoy se celebra en el mundo este
día y Vamos a repasar como siempre lo
hacemos algunas cifras una introducción
antes de empezar con las preguntas no
todos los trastornos de Salud Mental
realmente a nivel global tienen unas
proporciones difíciles de imaginar y de
sostener poniendo un ejemplo Raúl por
ejemplo la depresión es la segunda causa
de años vividos con discapacidad en el
mundo no en todo el mundo es la segunda
causa que más nos incapacita la
depresión en total en todo el mundo una
de cada ocho personas viven con algún
problema o alguna enfermedad de Salud
Mental y la prevalencia mundial está
entre el 11 el 13%, pero vemos
diferencias regionales en el continente
americano según datos de la OMS elea 15%
de la salud de la población americana
vive con algún problema de Salud Mental
una cifra que va disminuyendo hasta el
10% en África Aunque eso puede responder
Pues a problemas por ejemplo de
diagnóstico este año el lema Pues por la
campaña global por la Salud Mental es
que sea una prioridad en todo el mundo
pero la verdad es que por ahora sigue
siendo algo de lo que todavía estamos
lejos no es un problema de segunda
frente a otros problemas de salud y
sobre todo más después de la pandemia de
cube 19 pero le preguntó Cómo digamos
responden a un sistema de salud a estas
necesidades claro cada caso es diferente
y es difícil hacer una perspectiva
Global en todo el mundo pero sí tenemos
un dato por ejemplo Y es que el 2% del
presupuesto de salud de los gobiernos es
lo que se destina a problemas de salud
mentales decir de todo el presupuesto de
salud de media solo el 2% va a este tipo
de problemáticas Y como siempre los
países de ingresos bajos o de ingresos
bajos medios son los que menos acceso
tienen a profesionales Aquí vemos que
Pues apenas llega a una profesional por
cada 100.000 habitantes entonces bueno
eso como sabemos dificulta el
diagnóstico no tener diagnóstico
dificultad no tener tratamiento Y eso
significa Pues que la enfermedad empeora
que empeora el estigma que la calidad de
vida se degrada Y por último terminar
con esto no el último reporte de la OMS
determina también que las personas con
condiciones graves de Salud Mental
pueden morir hasta diez años antes que
la media de la población general bueno
lamentable cifras amar y saludamos
entonces a nuestra invitada del día de
hoy Violeta Naranjo psicóloga de la
fundación Universitaria conrad Lawrence
especialista en psicología clínica de la
Universidad Católica de Colombia y
maestrante en psicología clínica de la
fundación Universitaria conrad Lawrence
Gracias Violeta por estar con nosotros
esta mañana lunes en directo América de
Francia 24 un gusto
mucho gusto muchas gracias a ustedes por
invitarme doctora queríamos empezar con
una pregunta no alrededor de de la
atención que está recibiendo la Salud
Mental últimamente la Salud Mental está
en el centro de muchas conversaciones
también como decíamos a raíz de la
pandemia pero no sé si eso pues
obviamente tiene cosas positivas o si
también podemos caer en una banalización
Ok pues Bueno realmente tiene aspectos
positivos en términos de que lo
visibiliza hace pues esto existe no es
algo que que si lo tapamos desaparece y
pues realmente ha incrementado cada vez
más sin embargo lo que tú dices de
banalización podría tenerse en cuenta en
el término de de volverse la moda no y
es no estoy deprimido la depresión no
tengo ataques de ansiedad y y y
va a analizarlo en términos de tampoco
tener un tratamiento un seguimiento sino
de esto sigue pasando a todos nos pasa o
pues decir que tengo depresión cuando no
lo tengo claro también yo le quería
preguntar porque son tan difíciles de
priorizar estas enfermedades de Salud
Mental porque hay tanto silencios
también alrededor No también lo hablamos
más no sé si te acuerdas el día de la
bipolaridad la gente también fácil lo
dice no que yo soy Bipolar que estoy
deprimido como hacer eso algo fácil un
cuando en verdad es algo bien grave lo
que le ocurre a las personas que lo
padecen
Bueno ahí ahí vienen varios aspectos y
es el lenguaje el lenguaje cotidiano
versus el profesional en la cotidianidad
el estoy depre el me dio la crisis bueno
quizás estoy sufriendo una dificultad
pero como nadie me entiende entonces
digo así soy bipolar pero pues nunca el
no hablarlo es difícil porque hay
desconocimiento y el lenguaje popular o
lo utiliza para banalizarlo o por el
contrario
se estigma tú eres la persona con
depresión es una persona no es ansioso
él tiene el trastorno de ansiedad y fue
etiquetado y toma medicamentos Entonces
está como corrido tiene un problema se
le corrió La teja como se dice aquí
coloquialmente y eso pues genera un
impacto en las personas en que no se
quiera hablar en que esto se maneje de
otra forma e inclusive dentro de los
mismos profesionales de la salud existe
estas estigmatización la forma o el
enfoque es del que se ve es como
el etiquetado el enfermo o el que
necesita medicación y un trato diferente
entonces eso no facilita pues lo que tú
dices que las personas desde los medios
también no tenemos gran responsabilidad
sobre cómo hablamos de estas cosas
también lo como decías lo vamos a ese
día quería preguntarle no también qué
podemos hacer desde los medios de
comunicación para combatir esta
estigmatización de la que estaba
hablando tanto pues la bipolaridad es un
ejemplo pero también por ejemplo cómo
hablamos del suicidios otra cosa que
hemos tratado aquí no queríamos saber
sus recomendaciones
bueno Muchas gracias por este espacio y
esa recomendaciones serían varias la
primera es por ejemplo referente al
suicidio específicamente hay que hablar
hay que hablar que las personas hablen o
sea yo puedo Yo cualquier persona en el
mundo puede tener un pensamiento
relacionado a la muerte a la pérdida de
sentido y eso No necesariamente quiere
decir que yo me quiero morir o Me quiero
matar estoy en una situación en la que
realmente acabar con mi vida
me llega a la mente algo automático pero
No necesariamente es lo que yo quiero
estoy pasando por una situación y al
hablarlo eso me va a permitir que otras
personas me den su punto de vista quizás
me apoyen se Tomen las medidas
pertinentes Entonces desde los medios de
comunicación que se hablen que sé que no
se tenga miedo a hablar de tú este
pensamiento y que se estimule a las
personas a eso claro por otro lado
entender que la de por ejemplo la
depresión necesariamente como etiqueta
trastorno o enfermedad está pero
realmente a nivel mundial cualquier
persona va a desarrollar a lo largo de
su vida un episodio depresivo por
situaciones personales por dificultades
por pérdidas entonces también entender
que esto no es a los de allá sino a
todos todos nosotros vamos a pasar o
hemos pasado por alguna situación o
episodio en el que pues no nos sentimos
También estamos bajos de ánimo dejamos
de hacer cosas importantes y es
reconocer que esto a todos nos pasa y
nos va a pasar aunque sea un episodio
quizás no la etiqueta y aprender a
entender eso nos permite también
digámoslo así disminuir el nivel de
miedo hablar de esto porque básicamente
es el miedo a hablar a hacer etiquetado
o a mí eso no me pasa Yo soy de los de
acá no los de allá Pues noticias
cualquier persona en el mundo va va
garantizado a tener un episodio
depresivo aunque sea una vez en su vida
si definitivamente esto es uno de los
mensajes de hoy no puede pasar a todo el
mundo pero tampoco deja de ser acierto
que hay muchos factores de riesgo No
ahorra pues detrás de los de los
problemas de los trastornos de Salud
Mental que son sociales no estamos
hablando de pobreza estamos hablando de
discriminación de género y
discriminación Pues por orientación
asexual por identidad de género por
desplazamientos por ahora mismo también
se habla mucho de la crisis climática y
como esto también afecta a las
poblaciones más jóvenes que cargan con
el peso de tener que vivir a esto en el
futuro y a mí me surge esa cuestión no
tratamos a veces la Salud Mental como un
problema individual no estás mal ve a
terapia estás mal ve a buscar un
tratamiento Cómo debemos responder a
esto de forma colectiva también
Bueno ahí tienes un punto muy importante
dentro de todo lo que es las ciencias
del comportamiento o todo lo que
conocemos como estudio de las emociones
de la mente hablamos de un modelo
biopsicosocial la psicología no es algo
que está en el mundo de las ideas o que
está por ahí que uy a esta persona justo
se le fue la mente por allá no está en
algo que es biológico están algo social
cultural y genera un impacto a nivel
emocional Entonces
cómo podríamos atenuarlo bueno quizás
fortaleciendo claramente todos los
programas de prevención y promoción
entendiendo que la pobreza es una
vulnerabilidad el tener personas o
familiares que no han sido tratados al
tener dificultades o patologías en Salud
Mental me genera una vulnerabilidad todo
el tema actual guerras posibles cambios
climáticos pues todo eso va a impactar
Así que promover esos programas de y
promoción en Salud Mental y a la vez de
atenuar los riesgos sociales podría pues
facilitar una mejor Salud Mental y
también me quiero agarrar de la
acotación que acabas de hacer en un
momento porque sin duda también Violeta
la pandemia empeoró todo el panorama
global hablando de la Salud Mental no
digamos también tanto tiempo en
confinamientos luego salir nuevamente a
la calle no saber cómo comportarnos en
un principio después de tanto tiempo
encerrados entonces Violeta Cómo estamos
hoy en día todavía nos está afectando
todo eso que vimos en la pandemia que
por supuesto Todavía no se ha acabado
porque seguimos viviendo con el covid 19
evidentemente menor escala pero todavía
está la enfermedad entre nosotros y por
supuesto las heridas que eso dejó tanta
muerte y y pues de tanto encierro
bueno efectivamente lo que dice es
realmente sí sí nos ha seguido afectando
hoy en día en consulta lo vemos
constantemente vemos niños y
adolescentes con dificultades en
habilidades sociales muy marcadas y
Realmente si es a causa o como
consecuencia de esta pandemia y del
encierro porque claro
se empezó a normalizar el estar aislado
el estar solo el solo interactuar en
línea entonces pues lo creas uno uno
dice Bueno ya ya pasó un tiempo la gente
debe salir Tú encuentras que hay
personas que no salen y se quedan en
casa cuatro meses salen a hacer cosas un
mes luego salen a lo necesario pero ha
impactado y ese aislamiento hace que nos
hayamos vuelto Islas y eso afecta
totalmente nuestra salud mental porque
nosotros nos estamos interactuar hablar
con el otro de cómo me siento Cómo se
siente el otro ayudar al otro porque
somos seres sociales nos guste o no y
todo lo tecnológico y lo virtual
incrementó lo que ha facilitado
comunicaciones lejanas por ejemplo que
hagamos esta entrevista Pero ha
disminuido la conexión entre las
personas
cercanas y eso eso no es algo bueno para
para la salud mental ni para digamos la
vida plena de las personas claro a raíz
también de la pandemia por ejemplo
salieron noticias que hablaban del
aumento del consumo de psicofármacos o
de antidepresivos también de
ansiolíticos sobre todo No eso pues son
cifras que salían en Argentina México en
España pero que estoy segura que podemos
extender a varios otros países de la
región latinoamericana Hay demasiadas
personas buscando ahí la respuesta a los
problemas que los están aquejando sin
por supuesto Pues al menos cavar las
personas que necesitan de una medicación
para poder funcionar en su día a día
sobreponerse a una enfermedad no pero
sea se ha generalizado este consumo de
una forma algo Abusiva digamos entre
algunas personas
bueno digamos que ahí ahí son varias
cosas aquí por ejemplo en Colombia no es
que tú tengas acceso tan fácil a
psicofármaco tú debes tener digamos una
orden médica y todo el apoyo ahí médico
y lo que yo he visto desde mi consulta
privada y pues desde el entorno es que
realmente también las personas entienden
que el medicamento me cura cierto
Entonces no yo yo yo tomo esto y ya pero
Desafortunadamente la Salud Mental no
funciona así la Salud Mental si no tiene
una intervención psicoterapéutica el
psicofármaco ayuda a corto plazo pero a
largo plazo no genera una modificación
comportamental o ambiental o de las
dinámicas entonces claro se abusa de
estos porque a corto plazo es más fácil
tú te sientes en un ataque toma el
psicofármaco y te disminuye la
intensidad emocional sin embargo el tema
de la salud todo lo que es las
organizaciones de la salud en este caso
aquí hablamos de
bueno servicios de salud
de las ciudades se utiliza mucho el
psicofármaco inclusive desde
profesionales que no son los
especializados como psiquiatras sino
médicos generales que te envían esto por
qué Porque es más rápido es más sencillo
tiene menos costo versus por ejemplo una
psicoterapia que tiene una fase de
evaluación intervención seguimiento que
te puede durar de cuatro meses a un año
y Los costos entonces claro Se
incrementa también la toma de
medicamentos porque se han incrementado
las consecuencias de afectación la salud
emocional y como la tenemos con
medicamento por costos también
Por supuesto Siempre teniendo pendiente
entonces esa esa intervención social que
estaba dejando Claro que necesitamos
también todos pues para mejorar nuestra
salud mental y sobre todo las personas
que sufren estos trastornos
como decía también es Violeta todos en
la vida hemos tenido episodios
depresivos o cualquier otro tipo de de
cosas relacionadas no con nuestra salud
mental Gracias Violeta por estar con
nosotros esta mañana lunes en directo
América de Francia 24
muchas gracias a ustedes que tengan un
feliz día Violeta Naranjo psicóloga de
la fundación Universitaria conrad
Lawrence especialista en psicología
clínica la Universidad Católica de
Colombia maestrante en psicología
clínica fundación Universitaria contra
Lorenz por supuesto Gracias a ti también
por acompañarnos en estos temas de salud
como siempre ra